The jogan Experience what do you think
about usata getting
replaced I'm not I don't know exactly
what the new protocol is going to be but
I but I have heard that they're not
going to let them take bpc 157 and I'm
like what the [__] are you doing so
they're adhering to like the Water band
substance list presumably allegedly but
it could be you know like a little
little wink a little nod I don't know I
don't know how they're going to do it
and only time we'll tell I think this
current administration's contract with
usada is still applicable for the next
few months yeah yeah I think you sat uh
standard protocol is in place until
January 1 is that what it is yeah yeah
it's going to be interesting and you
know that's why I'm going to turn to you
to say like what do you think's going on
here yeah I guess it depends how they
document the positive test results too
because it's like back in the day
depending on organization sometimes
they'll publish exactly what the person
popped for what happened what you know
uh scrutiny is happening to them in the
moment um how it's being further
reviewed and it was like you know very
negative press even before they've
actually confirmed and proved this guy
cheated necessarily and then youat kind
of took this different angle where they
would kind of be a little bit more vague
about it and then they would get some
scrutiny about if they're covering up
for certain people but at the same time
they were like you know getting scrutiny
for being hyper stringent where they'd
like show up to guys places in the
middle of the [__] night when they're
trying to sleep
yeah and it's uh a
very as far as the new organization
their level of scrutiny and how it's
going to play out and how I don't know
private they're going to keep the
results it's to be determined but if
they're following the same Water band
substance list with the same kind of
protocols I imagine it's going to be
similar but with uh from what I
understand more scrutinous testing on
some of the endogenous bioidenticals so
like EPO I think nitzky said they're
going to up their frequency of testing
cuz you know some of this stuff at the
end of the day there's only so much
budget to allocate to where it's still a
viable economic thing so it's like are
you going to EPO test like every [__]
sample of every single athlete however
many times a year like some people are
tested like I don't know I forget what
Yuri was tested it was like some insane
amount of times per year um are you
going to EPO test HGH isopor test them
you know Carbon isotel ratio test are
going to do that on every sample he's
ever produced right probably not so you
got to have some reproducible
economically viable strategy but um I
think they tested Yuri a lot because he
was in recover from shoulder surgery too
yeah but then it's like why isn't guys
like you know Connor getting tested out
the ass because he got out of the pool
yeah but even when he went back in the
pool it's like well now he's testing how
frequently though well I don't know they
just started testing him really recently
guy's face definitely still looks a bit
Saucy well he was
jacked and also
that's when you should do it when you
have something like a catastrophic leg
injury I mean he's got rods in his legs
he's had multiple surgeries it's not
just one yeah you know I and then you
know it doesn't always heal right and it
breaks again like Dan hooker he has a
rod in his arm he broke his forearm in a
fight um I think it was the Jaylen
Turner fight and so he had it fixed had
a rods put in he just broke it again so
now he has to have a second surgery he
has to have that they're doing some new
proced try to get the bones to fuse cuz
the bones didn't fuse correctly and you
know the rods were the only thing
holding it in place and it snapped it's
really weird how they justify certain
compounds that can be in and out of
testing because it's like you could
abuse the [__] out of amphetamines out
of competition but then you can't use
bpc like like how does that make any
sense doesn't make any sense it's it's
all bizarre and I think in a perfect
world professional athletes would
utilize everything possible to get the
best possible performance again my only
concern would be young people ruining
their endocrine system yeah and then the
possible mitig you know the pro There's
real issues with overuse like overd
dosing because if you tell someone hey
if you take you know 100 milligrams of
this thing you'll have an improved
performance okay what's going to give me
a stroke yeah if I take 200 milligrams
what happens do I do do I move twice as
fast like what happens yeah and some of
the weight cutting will get even more
extreme with diuretic use and right yeah
some of it you'll have like kidney
failures pre- competitions right and
then the question is going to be like
what kind of testing protocol are they
going to use is it going to be random
you know is is it going to be something
you can game like you know I know who
was the athlete that was taking those
testosterone gummies and they were in
and out of your system in a short period
of time Alex Rodriguez there you go he
was taking a bunch of different [__] but
you were they were taking testosterone
gummies that you know would only stay in
your system for a few hours as of now
and I Stay pretty on top of the
literature it's still very uh you can
still circumvent the tests even with
highest scrutiny so you know with things
like test
EPO I've seen upwards of 50% of subjects
in studies getting around test trying to
find if they're doping like knowing that
they're using guys in the study as
subjects of you're getting micro doed
EPO and we're going to test you for it
rigorously and still passing even when
they're trying to catch them via the
study parameters so I think a lot of
people are going to be doing the same
[__] they've been doing I think the
scrutiny is going to be similar probably
but perhaps more uh like at least nitz's
framing it like there's more budget
being allocated to some of the more
rigorous tests but I don't know I
imagine it'll be similar but I've also
heard that this organization also works
with the NBA and some other uh Pro
Sports which are traditionally seen as
pretty LAX in contrast yeah so I would
imagine it's going to be a little more
more LAX and i would support that yeah I
I I certainly support guys taking things
to recover from injuries like Connor did
with his leg injury 100% no question
about it I'm 100% all in on that that's
the only way no one comes back from that
no one has ever come back from that
catastrophic leg break yeah the shin
break not a single athlete has come back
from it and performed at the same level
Anderson Silva is the only guy who came
back and fought multiple times and he
was not the same guy yeah yeah it's uh I
don't know like Conor's definitely got a
got a win when he [__] comes back
like he it's kind of like his legacy
like not entirely hinged on it or
anything but I mean it's he's got a lot
to live up to to not just oh yeah yeah
but also if you were a coach and you
wanted to look at this in terms of a
long-term career strategy I would want a
tuneup fight yeah 100% I would not want
him going right in there against Islam
makev yeah he's still trying to go like
balls deep and pick the hardest dudes
well that's him that's why he's a
champion that's why he's a warrior I
mean he he feels like he could just get
but one of the things that he said about
the Dustin porier fight the first one uh
the first the second fight but the first
one of the most recent ones where he got
knocked out he said I was inactive he
goes it just uh it caught up to me I
could feel it I could feel it while was
in there my timing wasn't as good you
know you need to be active to be at the
the highest levels of world class mixed
martial arts competition I just don't
see how you can take two years off
multiple surgeries get on juice get off
juice and then jump in there against the
best in the world maybe he can do it but
if I was his coach and the option was
available I'd say Let's get someone
who's not even in the top 15 let's get
some guy who is beatable but a good test
it's a we'll call it a tuneup fight you
we get to see how you perform this guy
gets an opportunity to beat Conor
McGregor you get an an opportunity to
test your skills again and feel the
lights and feel the pressure get your
timing back have that fight 6 months
later you have a big fight do you know
when UFC 300 would be like that seems
like a pretty big event that they would
probably when is that supposed to be
jerie ail I think April I think is that
too soon for him to be fighting well
there's a six-month thing in the pool
right so here we are in November
contingent on usada though yeah and
contingent on whe right right if you saw
is out maybe they don't have a six-month
thing anymore right point I wonder if
he's uh like obviously that's an event
you would think he'd be in I would think
I you would definitely want him in that
event but then the thing is like here's
a good
question if you give someone an
exemption you let them take get out of
the
pool and they're taking some hardcore
steroids to heal their their Shin break
what how much gain do you maintain from
that that Improvement in your
performance cuz it's not zero no it's uh
I think a lot of it is also indirect
through the time in the gym and skill
acquisition because a lot of people
Overlook the recovery capacity enhancing
component so it's like if you're able to
it's not just about how much muscle
you've gained and objective measurements
of oh your bench press went up by x
amount it's also how many more hours
were you able to train relative to your
competition because of this and that's
that many more hours working on X skill
this skill that doing your endurance
whatever you're able to do more things
and have more bandwidth allocated to
your you know skill uh I don't know
sustaining or you know development so as
far as the studies go for retention of
what's called myonuclei like how much
you can actually Bank up from steroid
use it doesn't seem to be something
that's going to sustain for I don't know
in perpetuity like we once thought is
kind of finicky if that's actually
something that happens or not like a lot
of people will still shrink back down
when they come off
but he's competing pretty soon after
being like what appeared to be pretty
[__] full board like the guy was
essentially unrecognizable compared to
traditional you know Connor yeah he
looked like a light heavyweight yeah it
was like to me his face looked like the
first time a guy takes gear like oh wow
you've gained like 15 pounds of water
yeah yeah yeah everything got big so
yeah like it didn't even look like it
was an attempt to do it in a you know
I'm trying to micro do way it's like a
real cycle seemingly right so and why
not if you're not being tested and you
can so and it's probably fun yeah yeah
yeah I yeah for sure but the question is
like when it comes to Performance like
physical ability strength power speed
you don't go back to zero so no I think
you would retain some of it what like
how much of it that would be so
speculative so I think
speculate like let's say a guy takes one
cycle of testosterone at like a
traditional amount that guys use like
500 milligrams is a pretty common like
bodybuilder starting level cycle is that
per week yeah 500 milligrams per week
okay so that's like you know three to
three and a half times what a
traditional trt dose would be that would
gain you you know a significant amount
of lean mass and strength and you would
probably sustain that for again as the
hormones work its way out your system
even as they're residually leaving you
still have that bleed of hormone that's
sustaining even during your training
subjecting yourself to you know even if
you had poor sleep heavy weight cutting
like you still have synthetic drug that
is bleeding out of your system and
holding at least nonfluctuating values
other than the bleedout time so the size
difference yeah it's wild look at him
2022 he's [__] massive the face
difference is like the most staggering
to me too look at his neck so weight cut
I don't know how that difference dude
that shot with with him on the bottom
left yeah with his arm around the dude
he looked oh they cut off his quads but
his quads looked [__] nutty in that
picture yeah the one where it shows him
at the bottom of those three photographs
Jamie that is when he made weight for
145 though a Skeletor bro yeah he was
literally starving himself that's wild
he was starving himself he looks like
one of those Like Pirates of the
Caribbean yeah monsters yeah that's what
he looked like back then so yeah think
that you know within the span of
competing within a year like you're
going to
retain um it would take depending on how
fast the compound would work its way to
your system depends on the estra chosen
like I'm sure you're familiar with your
testosterone is probably a testosterone
cypionate for example so that like
determines how long it will hold uh take
to metabolize out of your body so that
one has close to a 10day halflife so
that would take 50 days essentially to
clear out of your system so for for him
if you cleared out something that took
50 days to get out like you would still
have residual benefit for months
thereafter for sure and whether it's
going to be 100% or 0% you know I would
speculate it be somewhere in the middle
you know you're going to lose a lot of
the temporary weight fairly rapidly
though like a lot of that blood volume
water retention will dissipate within
the first number of weeks and then after
that you're kind of whatever tissue
you've accumulated will slowly go over
the next months which you'd probably
retain I don't know I would say half by
the time he maybe 25 to 50% but that's
you
know